good afternoon everybody
i'm assistant sheriff andrew walsh and
i'm here to brief you on the additional
details as we know them today about the
officer involved shooting that occurred
on thursday august 11 2022
this is officer involved shooting number
seven for this year and it's the third
non-fatal officer-involved shooting
we've had so far in 2022. at the same
time last year we had five
officer-involved shootings and three of
those being non-fatal
this event was initiated as a follow-up
investigation on august 11th at 501 pm
before i get into the details of the
officer-involved shooting i wanted to
give you some backdrop to the history of
the follow-up investigation
on may 20th
of this year officers responded to a
violent carjacking that occurred in the
area of north los feliz street and
stewart avenue
during this robbery
a white male adult
stole a vehicle at gunpoint from a 73
year old female victim
officers then
identified the suspect and on the day of
the officer-involved shooting they were
conducting covert surveillance at his la
cover surveillance at his last known
address
and there were two separate locations
where officers discharged their weapon
during this officer-involved shooting
the first officer-involved shooting
occurred in the area of 5th street and
craig road which is located in north las
vegas
the second officer-involved shooting
location occurred at the 4800 block of
west desert inn road in las vegas which
is in this
spring valley area command and you can
see both of these areas depicted on the
screen and the maps to my left
there were five officers that were
involved in this officer-involved
shooting the first officer is officer
brendan burbrink he is 36 years old and
has been with the lvmpd since 2015.
in this incident officer burbrink was
armed with the smith and wesson m p nine
millimeter equipped with the tactical
light and the investigation revealed
that he fired eight rounds
the second officer involved is officer
christian maharo he is 27 years old and
has been with the lvmpd since 2021.
in this incident officer mahara was
armed with a glock 17 nine millimeter
equipped with the tactical light and the
investigation revealed that he fired
four rounds
the third officer involved in this
incident is officer alondra montero
she is 24 years old and has been with
the lvmpd since 2021.
in this incident officer montero was
armed with a glock 17 nine millimeter
equipped with the tactical light and the
investigation revealed that she fired
eight rounds
the fourth officer is officer amanda
montalto
she is 31 years old and has been with
the lvmpd since 2017.
in this incident officer montalto was
armed with a glock 19 nine millimeter
equipped with the tactical light and the
investigation revealed that she fired
eleven rounds during this incident and
the fifth officer involved in this
incident is officer mark sayus or
cesaius is 35 years old and has been
with the lvmpd since 2019
this investigation revealed that officer
says fired six rounds during this
incident and all the officers i just
named are assigned to the community
policing division and they all work at
the northeast area command in this
incident the suspect was identified as
justin lee venegas
justin is a forty year old white male
adult he's approximately five foot five
and weighs about 150 170 pounds and he
is pictured
on the screen to my left
and the investigation revealed that
during this incident venegas was armed
with a smith and wesson m p nine
millimeter pistol and he also used a
stolen white chevy avalanche as a weapon
when he intentionally rammed one of our
canine vehicles and the investigation
revealed that during this incident
office uh excuse me the suspect venegas
fired a total of four rounds now venegas
faces several charges stemming from the
officer involved shooting i'll read
those off to you now
venegas has been charged with three
counts three counts of attempted murder
with a deadly weapon on a protected
person one count of battery with a
deadly weapon on a protected person
one count of attempted murder with a
deadly weapon
one count of attempted robbery
one count of discharging a firearm at a
moving vehicle
one count of robbery with deadly weapon
and one count of felony evading
now stemming back to the may incident
venegas has been charged with robbery
with a deadly weapon with a victim over
sixty two counts of assault with a
deadly weapon with a victim over sixty
two counts of assault with a deadly
weapon
and grand larceny auto
now i'll give you the details for the
officer involved shooting
on august 11 2022 plainclothes officers
were conducting a follow-up
investigation at justin venegas's last
known address in the northeast part of
the valley
officers saw vanegas enter a vehicle and
drive out of the area
the air unit was requested to assist in
following venegas as he left the area
and drove away
while following venegas the air unit saw
him get out of his vehicle and point a
firearm at the driver of a white chevy
avalanche in the area of north pecos
road and cheyenne avenue and then
venegas while the air unit was watching
proceeded to carjack that vehicle and
drive away in the chevy avalanche
after the violent robbery at
approximately 7 13 pm patrol officers
tried to pull venegas over
the vehicle pursuit was initiated and
banegas failed to stop for the mock
patrol officers an unmarked lvmpd
vehicle became part of the pursuit and
that vehicle is equipped with police
lights and sirens and was behind the
venegas during this vehicle pursuit
venegas suddenly came to an abrupt stop
causing the unmarked police vehicle to
crash into the back of the stolen
vehicle
the collision disabled the police
vehicle and the officer was subsequently
transported to the hospital for minor
injuries mark patrol units continued to
pursue venegas and attempted a pit
maneuver in the area of craig road and
north fifth street and as you know from
previous incidents in previous press
briefings pitt stands for the precision
intervention technique and is designed
defined as a specific manner of
intentional contact using a police
vehicle against a fleeing vehicle during
a pursuit to cause the fleeing vehicle
to come to an abrupt stop rendering it
immobile
venegus avoided the fit the pit by
shooting at officers two times
from the with his firearm and striking
the windshield of the patrol vehicle
officer brendan burbrink who was a
passenger in the patrol vehicle fired
five rounds from his duty weapon through
the windshield
officer burbrink's rounds impacted the
rear of the stolen vehicle however
venegas was not struck
after the shooting venegus continued to
evade officers in the stolen vehicle
throughout the pursuit venegas drove
through red lights and displayed
reckless behavior as he drove around
congested areas of traffic and at times
his speeds would reach in excess of 100
miles per hour
as venegas approached the intersection
of desert inn road and jones boulevard
he forced the female motorist to a stop
he attempted to steal her vehicle by
jumping out of the white chevy avalanche
and ran towards her with the gun in his
hand attempting to get her out of her
vehicle the driver of this vehicle was
able to put her vehicle in reverse and
as she backed away vegas fired upon her
thankfully this victim of this attempted
robbery wasn't seriously hindered or
hurt by the gunfire and she was treated
at the scene by medical personnel and
released
venegas then ran back to the original
stolen chevy avalanche and fled
eastbound on desert inn as police
officers and marked vehicles attempted
to catch up with him a short time later
venegas drove into a busy grocery store
shopping center located at the 4800
block of west desert in road
again venegas attempted to carjack
another vehicle with his gun in the
parking lot but was unsuccessful
he got back into the
stolen chevy avalanche as officers were
arriving in the parking lot and he
started to drive towards the officers
who had exited their patrol vehicles and
were telling him to stop the car benegas
ignored those commands and continued to
drive toward the officers
as a result of venegas actions officers
brendan burbrink christian
christian maharo alondra montero amanda
montalto and mark sayus opened fire on
venegas venegas was not shot but the
avalanche was struck multiple times
still vegas continued benegas continued
to drive northbound on decatur boulevard
at a high rate of speed until he spotted
a stopped canine unit in the area of
decatur and fair center
venegus crossed several lanes of traffic
and in a deliberate attempt to injure or
kill our k9 officer he crashed into him
head on and this violent impact caused
both vehicles to become disabled
the subsequent investigation revealed at
the time of impact
venegas was traveling at 67 miles per
hour
arriving officers were able to take
venegas into custody without further
incident and the canine officer was
transported to the hospital by arriving
units he has since been released in his
home recovering from his injuries
the patrol dog canine boris fortunately
was not injured during this incident but
he was taken to be evaluated and cleared
by veterinary personnel
venegus was also transported to umc
trauma for his injuries and he has since
been released from the car count
released from the hospital and booked
into the clark county detention center
now we have a bunch of video to play for
you some of it is from the air unit and
some of it is from body worn camera and
we have some video that was actually
captured by a citizen that caught the
actual collision between venegas and our
k9 officer
so this is the original carjacking near
cheyenne and pecos venegas is in the
great car to the right and that's the
white chevy avalanche i described
and we'll let it play from here
so when venegas exits the vehicle you'll
see him point the firearm at the
citizens
uh
so this is the first officer-involved
shooting where you'll notice the
attempted pit maneuver
and then
the shots come through the windshield of
the patrol vehicle and then the officer
fires back
and this is the body-worn camera
angle of that
footage you got it
try this
[Music]
oh
[Music]
no this is the second attempted
carjacking or the attempted carjacking
that occurred near deserting and jones
that's the centerpiece
if you slow it down now on desert
unfortunately might be trying to hijack
someone else yeah he's out of his
vehicle
his car's running he's got a gun pointed
out of the victim here he's firing into
the victim vehicle we have to get him
stopped
[Music]
come on
[Music]
and this is as he pulls into the smith's
parking
all right looks like he's lot into the
smith's parking lot possibly to carjack
somebody else he's forcing somebody into
the uh the parking lot and is into the
smiths parking lot
all right stop for another vehicle
uh he's
[Music]
he's uh parking now in the do you see
where the camper trailer is in the
parking lot is directly uh right to the
south side out of the vehicle running
through the complex his equal movement
get in here guys minivan get right in
front of that mini man he's been on the
window trying to get in
get on the ground all right get that car
blocked dude get back in it get all the
way up to the block if you can he is
shot it picked uh civilians so we get
that thing blocked in get it done
all right control ar5
officers are they have shots fired again
shots fired at the vehicle watch out for
your crossfire guys watch after
crossfire got active traffic there are
just less of you no more fires he's out
onto the caterer
and this is body one camera from the
shopping center parking lot
uh
is
[Music]
and this is the vehicle
uh the video of the canine collision the
first
video will be from the air unit
so if you watch
up to the left here you'll see the k9
unit on the left hand side
major intersection we've got very light
traffic between here at charleston
takes up by the freeway field
description again please need this major
401 with our patrol vehicle roll two
medicals for me please major 401 with
our patrol vehicle
officer
and this is the citizen footage from
uh
a dash cam is the best way to describe
it that captures the collision with the
k-9 officer
[Music]
this chamber is like sprayed by all of
these different nozzles
and the last piece of footage we have
this is the k-9 officer's body-worn
camera footage
[Music]
major intersection we've got very high
traffic that we hear ourselves
video description again
[Music]
and that's concludes this briefing
any questions
yes sir um i guess my initial impression
here uh you've got officers who are
continuing to pursue the suspect bullet
holes in their windshield of course the
k9 officer goes the opposite lane of
traffic eventually ends this pursuit i
guess just comment on the bravery
involved in here well i think the videos
are
a great way for
you all to see what our officers do
every day and the kind of things that
they're confronted with on a daily basis
there's this type of evil
that exists out there and
you know bravery is one way to put it
you know it's uh you know they suit up
every day and go out there and this is
what they deal with
uh there's no other way to put it
good
denise a couple of the cars had two
people so for a few of these trains
so
you know
did they do exactly what they were
trying to do yeah they we had two
officers that were in field training
that were driving vehicles in this
incident uh you could see from you know
some of the footage that uh you know
they're taking direction from their
field training officers on what to do uh
but this does speak to the training that
they go through in the police academy
and taking stuff that they learn in a
very static environment and apply it to
this dynamic world
that's out there when they get out into
field training
and as far as the pursuit goes i know a
lot of times you just choose not to
pursue is this one of those rare cases
where
you need it yeah you know the
cornerstone of our pursuit policy is
obviously to have supervisory
involvement and from the very beginning
that's what we had on this uh and the
fact that we're dealing with a very
violent person from the crime that
occurred back in may
the decision to authorize the pursuit
was a sound decision based on the crimes
and then when you see
the footage of that bullet going through
the windshield of the police vehicle you
watch the footage of him shooting at a
citizen who's just driving down the
street and that could be any one of us
right at any given time uh driving down
the street and guy pulls in front of you
and jumps out with a gun and starts
shooting at you to take your car
so yeah it's one of those rare occasions
where you will see a pursuit that goes
as long and as far as this one did but
definitely appropriate under the
circumstances in our mission to protect
the community
yes sir a little bit but the dynamic of
communication plays in this because i
found it very interesting from the air
unit saying back off shots have been
fired at an officer tell me how
communication plays in it's a great uh
thing to have you know the air unit that
we have and in in this incident the
pilots and the operators there and that
ship did a great job of you know being
in charge of the radio and communicating
information to officers and articulating
what they see to help officers on the
ground make decisions so uh you know
we're really advanced when it comes to
the technology that the air unit has uh
so that is key in this instance and you
know he was driving at such high rates
of speeds that you know without the air
unit we clearly would have lost him and
this violent felon would have still been
out in the community so but the air unit
being able to control the radio and give
that direction to officers and keep them
updated is key uh definitely to the uh
our ability to stay with him on this
event yes sir how long have this guy
been under surveillance a couple hours
they had done surveillance the day
before
at that location came up with nothing
went back at it the second day and uh
they'd been there
not too long a couple hours
at most when he came out
you know we will look at everything from
what went into the surveillance and the
planning for all that and part of our
critical instant review process but you
know it's 72 hours into it it looks like
the people that planned that operation
and did everything appropriately within
our policy to get him into custody
can you describe the officer's injury
so the
the officers that were shot at just you
know a little bit of
broken glass from the from the first
incident they're fine they did not
require any type of medical treatment
but the officer in the canine vehicle
he has some uh a little bit of a road in
front of him uh you know a little bit of
a
some bruising some swelling a concussion
uh you know the doctors say mild
concussion i don't know how you can tell
the difference to be honest with you but
uh he's banged up pretty good you know
you get hit head-on by someone trying to
kill you at 67 miles an hour uh we're
very fortunate that we're not burying
that officer or the officers that were
shot at and went up
you know and the citizen you know she
has an injury to her arm that you know
uh it could be a grey's wound it could
be from the glass it could be a variety
of things so uh but i appreciate you
asking about our officer because when
you watch the violence that's associated
with that collision and you see that
video especially from the ground level
um we're lucky you know this community
was very lucky in this incident
i found it striking when he like said
boris are you okay he
yeah the relationship between a canine
operator and a handler and his uh dog
you know that's been well documented in
this community
over the years that
is a very special relationship and uh
you know hopefully
our officer recovers very quickly and
can be reunited with his dog
soon
the shots that were fired in the parking
lot area
i mean were there any stray bullets that
went around
no we're
we we're having a uh we we know the
number of rounds i just don't know top
my head that struck the avalanche and uh
you could see from the damage to the
front of the chevy avalanche that you
know it's going to take some time for us
to really get that apart and find all
the other rounds that were fired but now
we're uh you know
no stray rounds to any of the buildings
or
anything that was surrounding the area
uh during this incident so all right
thank you all very much